merci la parole et à madame véronique
louwagie merci monsieur le président
monsieur le premier ministre
dans quelques instants le dernier plf de
cette législature sera soumis au vote et
ma question porte sur le prélèvement à
la source en premier lieu sur la forme
votre majorité est particulièrement mal
à l'aise sur ce sujet preuve en est le
défaut de mobilisation de vos députés
qui n'a pas permis l'adoption de
l'article 38 jeudi matin cette péripétie
est révélatrice de la très grande
fragilité de votre gouvernement et d'une
majorité qui vous suit vraiment vraiment
du bout des lèvres
et ce alors même que vous avez su à
plusieurs reprises trouvé le soutien des
députés de l'opposition pour soutenir
les mesures responsables que vous
proposiez contre votre propre majorité
en second lieu sur le fond je veux
rappeler que ce texte comporte d'abord
des conséquences pour les contribuables
confronté à une complexité extrême avec
la mise à mal de la familiarisation et
de la conjugalité ation de l'impôt sur
le revenu ensuite un manque de
confidentialité des informations
personnelles et notamment de celle des
salariés également pour les entreprises
une charge accrue de travail et un
courtière d'adaptation des logiciels
comptables alors que l'adsl ne
fonctionne toujours pas partout de plus
une année de transition pleine
d'incertitudes pour le secteur du
bâtiment
les propriétaires ne pouvons déduire les
travaux en 2010 est de leurs revenus
fonciers ce qui les incitera à les
reporter il s'agit tout de même de 400
millions d'euros de travaux
alors dans ces conditions monsieur le
premier ministre pourquoi vous obstinez
vous encore et toujours à vouloir mettre
en place le prélèvement à la source et
de plus si cette réforme
et comme l'on dit vos ministres de
l'économie et du budget et je les cite
une belle réforme une grande réforme
faisant honneur à ce quinquennat
alors monsieur le premier ministre
pourquoi ne pas l'avoir fait en début de
mandat pensez vous
très sincèrement monsieur le premier
ministre pensez-vous loyal pensez-vous
digne pensez-vous moralement acceptable
de proposer cette réforme enfin à
demanda alors que vous savez très bien
vous le savez très bien que la mise en
oeuvre incombera à ceux qui vouent
succéderont juin 2010 l avant et ça
monsieur christian eckert secrétaire
d'état chargé du budget et des comptes
publics
merci monsieur le président madame la
députée louwagie
mesdames messieurs les députés je
voudrais rendre un smash madame le
député à l'une de vos collègues
madame schmid qui était la seule
vendredi sur les bancs de la droite à
côté du président caresse la seule si
cette réforme était aussi dangereuse
aussi mauvaise comment se fait-il que
les députés de l'opposition n'avaient
qu'un seul représentant
c'est une route pour l'exercice de la
démocratie
merci pour madame schmid
madame la députée sur le fond madame la
députée sur le fond vert cette somme ne
met en cause sans rien il vous plait
calmez-vous je sais que vous avez
certains sujets d'excitation ce moment
mais ça va bien se passer sur le fond
sur le fond madame le député cette
réforme est une réforme qui va mettre la
france au même standard que les autres
pays nous étions l'un des derniers à ne
pas pratiquer le prélèvement la source
alors madame louve agit il y a aucune
remise en cause de la familiarisation de
l'impôt aucune remise en cause de la
progressivité de l'impôt justement cette
réforme qui pour la première fois et
c'est historique a été adoptée par le
parlement alors que bien d'autres envier
avait rêvé de la faire
madame la députée sur ce sujet comme sur
d'autres sujets de société notamment
est-ce que l'opposition va un jour se
décider à rentrer dans la modernité
merci